hello everybody and welcome to the tenth
Python web development with flash
tutorial video in this video we're going
to be talking about message flashing
flashing is built into flask and what it
does is you can use it like a
notification so for example let me show
you on Python programming net what I'm
talking about so I come over here I'm
logged in I click logout there's this
little message here it just says you've
been logged out and I can exit out of it
same thing if I go to dashboard it says
welcome guests feel free to browse the
content level as the tracking stuff is
only available for logged in users which
is these tracking bars that I showed you
guys earlier
so and then again this can be xed out
that's all
a bootstrap code basically for the Xing
out and then the way that we flash
messages is flask now you can write your
own messaging system on your owner
really I think the better term I think
is it's a notification system you can
write yours on your own I actually have
my own kind of version of flash but you
the only time you would ever do that is
for like really custom stuff because you
can actually do a lot of really custom
stuff with flash so anyways let me move
this over and let's go ahead and get
started so first we're going to come
over here actually I think I already
have mine up in it dot PI and the first
thing we have to do is from flask after
all these imports we're going to also
import flash and then dashboard I've
deleted slash board because we don't
need it anymore in dashboard we're going
to go ahead and let's just run flash
real quick and we'll call it flash test
okay and like later on what you can do
though is you can say you can do
something like if user um not logged in
flash you know you're not logged in okay
something like that okay you can you can
add logic like that and then you don't
have to pass the flash through the
template so the best thing that you can
do to handle flashes is actually not via
each little file like dashboard and this
page in that page the best way to handle
it is actually within your header so
this is what extent or yeah all the
pages extend header so you come over to
your header now come down to the bottom
and just before block body you still
want it obviously within the container
so it kind of matches your styling of
your your body content and then within
here we're going to flash the messages
so the way that we're going to do that
is the following so we're going to use
some logic here and then this the first
logic is with messages equals get
underscore flash underscore messages
that's a function and basically what
this means is with the fact that four
messages so this messages variable
equals the return of get flashed
messages so with that what do we want to
do well we're going to first let's go
ahead and end end with before we forget
and then space space then we're going to
ask the question if messages so
basically what happens here is if there
are messages and we'll close off the end
if so if messages means if there's
anything like messages is even a defined
variable that's true if as if there's
nothing there that returns false and
this would stop
so if messages what do we want to do
well if there are messages we're going
to use a for loop because you might just
flash one message but there actually
might be like five messages that you
flash so you want each one to be handled
so now we're going to say for message in
messages what do we want to do well
first we're going to end before before
we forget it's very hard on us Python
folk
for message in messages what do we want
to do well we're going to use some
bootstrap stuff and we're going to
utilize div tags for that and basically
what we're going to say is div equals a
class or div class equals alert alert
I think warning is yellow so we'll say
alert warning uh you can also do info I
believe is going to be blue so that will
kind of match our website a little
better I didn't want to do info for
myself just simply because I had that
same color for the topics that I'll show
you guys later so warning and that's
probably best for a notification anyways
and it matches basically the blue and
yellow scheme that is the website and is
the Python colors so alert alert warning
again that is bootstrap code and then
also it is also a class alert - this
mint
oops dismissible the role is alert alert
there we go uh and then that's really it
for now we will add a button but for now
let's just add the message so let's just
say a message like this okay so that's
our header we can save that now we can
come over to our innate dot pi file we
are already flashing the test I don't
think we restarted a patchy so let's do
that and we'll refresh and now we get
flash test awesome and if we were to try
and think of any other page that we have
I guess we don't really have any other
page uh but let's go and add our at
least our X Out button
so here message now we want to add a
button that will allow us to dismiss
this so we need button tags button slash
button
and this is button type equals button
class equals clothes again this is a
bootstrap code data
- dismiss equals alert so we're just
missing this alert data dismiss equals
alerts area label label equals closed uh
and then finally let me see here yeah so
within here is where we're going to add
this little X so we've got the button
but now we need something that does it
so for example we could probably I
believe get away with clothes like this
let's refresh right so you've got
clothes we click it that goes away
obviously that's kind of annoying it's
not really I mean well first of all
we're zoomed way the hell in so it would
look like this and you can hit close but
I wouldn't mind having that X so the way
that I did the X is with the span tags
so you've got span / span it's really
hard once you get into this span span
and then the span here is space Aria -
hidden hidden equals true and then the
rest of the code was and x semicolon and
hopefully that gives us the X that we're
hoping for
sho'nuff there is the X if I forget to
edit out my face in the video I'm sorry
but you should see an X so this is also
part of the problem is from before
though is that this kind of bootstrap is
meant to be um you know resizable okay
so you can view it on a phone like this
or you could view it on a computer like
this now for some reason why I squish
this up and then pull it back out this
happens I don't know if I mentioned that
before
but I'm not sure why that happens but if
you refresh it it's fixed and that's not
really top priority for me to deal with
the people that do this to my website I
just don't care about you so anyway
uh-huh yeah
so flash test cool got that and again if
we did you know you might have multiple
things that you want to flash to the
user
um so whoops render okay save that
refresh or restart Apache start this so
you've got all these flashes here and so
on so anyway that's that um the last
thing let's see if we can contain our
file here let's go to the header so you
see uh I don't know which is our header
let's just close everything and come
back over here header okay so you've got
body this is your container this also
contains the body we can it says with
80% uh what if we say max with 80% I
would just like to fix this container ah
studio just regular container there we
go so it's not so annoying let's just do
with 80% okay so we can play with that a
little bit more later as far as how you
want to organize your content but
obviously when it's like the whole page
is kind of annoying right now our tabs
in our text or you know kind of small so
maybe you would want it bigger maybe one
everything left oriented I don't know
but that's how you can at least make it
so it's not you know spanning the entire
page if if you so choose so anyway I
think that's it for this tutorial so we
cover flash and all the things that we
can do with flash obviously again you're
going to use flash more so for like
logic and stuff but again just just to
show you we can change instead of having
it be an alert we can change it to info
and now it's blue I think the other I
think you can have like danger
is read I forget there's one for green I
don't remember what it is
maybe success let's try success and see
if I'm right
anyway but yeah you can have you know
multiple colors stuff like that
flash messaging system yeah I was right
just doesn't work with these colors
though anyway but also let's say you
wanted your own color you could add it
you go to the bootstrap dat CSS file
find the thing for alert - success right
or just the color of success and change
the value it's just hex color codes so
you could pick anything you wanted and
you could change the valleys it just so
happens that the bootstrap blue pretty
much matches the python blue so I saw no
purpose for really changing much and
then the yellow kind of works with it
I wouldn't want a super bright yellow
anyways but anyway that's it for this
tutorial if you have any questions or
comments please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support in
the subscriptions until next time